我就是因为他点这边
他点这边的时候就不知道
就是相当于在程序那边的启动和在仿真界面这边的启动
现在是有有两个地方的入口对用户来说是有脱节的
我可以共享屏幕
我看一下这个问题吗
我不是很理解
可以
你你你知道我从哪个地方
你的意思是那个
程序你不是写好了以后
那个地方不是要点一个运行下的
还有一个保存
对
保存那个地方
对要不时空这边来共享
享一下屏幕
我看到了你这些测试数据
到时候我找我们给我给那个环境给我的时候
我也能看到是吧
都能看到
给你的账号就是给你的账号就是那个好
还是电脑的话
可能我得想一下怎么弄
原先现实公司资源比较紧张
就是因为如果你用我的那台是可以的
但是我就不知道你的时间段
因为我日常的话可能现在有一些审批流
其实是在那台电脑上面做的
行
就最好这些东西它如果是运行在mac上
可能现在能想到要解决的问题有多少
这个很很困难吗
会有点麻烦
因为他很多库是依赖现在的那个的
这只要界面的起来就行了
就是你你现在看这个地方动作片
对这里有一个你看见没
这有保存有发送
就这里的交互我觉得你得改
就是这个地方你看到没有
对用户来说
他也不知道什么叫发送这个东西
对吧
其实他发送是去去到仿真或者需要真机
然后那边
就动
了对
但是对于用户来说
他其实对这块是理解上面是有问题
然后这个时候你的顶部还是有一个波那个运行
是不是
对然后那这两个逻辑其实现在没有统一
然后现在上面顶部的那个它其实是一个演示的脚本
这个对吧
对
就是把这两个统一
对不对
对
但是这个问题就牵扯到刚才前昨天我跟你聊的
就是因为纺织那边其实会多一些这个物体的状态什么那些东西
但是在程序这边是没有的
这个是后面要讲的那个问题
对
所以现在就变成就是说因为正常你点这个程序中的这个的话
运行它其实是不带那些信息的
对吧
明白所以为什么我们之前做成两个的原因就是这
但是现在对于
就对于我现在想了想
觉得这个可能得把后面的这个方案也想好了之后
再一起来去优化的对
就这个地方可能你还得想一下
因为现在对用户来说他是有有不理解的
如果我们不经过专门的培训的话
对于普通用户来说
他根本就不知道这里是怎么样一个操作流程
那其实如果要还是维持分开的方案
就相当于在那个嗯就最好是在动作编辑器那边的话
还是跟真机是直接相关的
默认的话然后你这个仿真这边的话
就是默认可以是他这个演示的版本跟真机无关的
然后他们互相之间都可以切换成为另外一种
但是他现在的那个程序是同一套
知道吧
他是同一套的
就是对我们他应该提到没有涉及到针灸
或者是说还有一种就是把甄姬这个的话就相当于是就明确告诉他是是下载运行
运行了之后
它会进入我们整套系统
会进入一个孪生的状态
对不对
对
反正就是你看一下怎么操作会更好一点
这个逻辑的原理
你知道问题点在哪里吗
知道了
那现在那现在那个仿仿真演示的那个脚本是哪个
也是这套代码
不是
施工给你
施工给你讲一下
哪个
就是这边的那个3D模型
对应的就是这个天梭图里面的一些组件
这些组件的话它它是跟那个硬件也是对应的
就是说这个组件的话是如果是接到硬件的话
他就他这边那lock你就可以控制硬件
如果他这边是仿真的话
那么这边会绑定这个硬件的属性
就比如说这里有一个
这里有一个绑定属性
就是跟那个建筑图里面的设备是一致的
绑定好了之后
他又可以去用这个去控制它
这个流程图里面他就这里面就可以调他的那个回线运动
回线运动
然后这个名称就是他们的箭头图的3D里面是保持一致的
然后这边运行代码之后就可以控制他
同时也可以控制硬件
那这个也这个脚本也是等于也是仿真的脚本
对
但是他唯独区别就是它不带那些物料的那个信息
比如说那个杯子对吧
那个杯子现在是不在这套程序里的对
然后他是在另外这个就是那天我跟你说的那个编辑那个那个界面下面编的
我们是可以考虑它是在同一套脚本里面的对吧
然后对
但是对于用户来说
对于实际的开发者来说
你可能要区分一下
因为如果我是一个调试工应用调试工程师的话
我其实不关心那个杯子是不是
我知道这点
我知道出现在那里的话
也要有一个明显的区分
或者是说临时把它给隐藏掉之类的这种
反正这上面是不运行的
对不对
是的
我考虑一下
对
然后现在是施工做了另外一个界面的菜单
是配置这个杯子的抓取的那个
你也把那个展示给我看
你之前介绍过
你忘了
对
你你你稍等
你可以让时工给你再看一遍
我这里有一个他这个补充行为的
就是说他到某一个地方
他处于那这个是有GP的当前状态
就是标
对
因为他这个要执行完
当前状态要执行完
他就会去触发当前的条件判断
有条件判断满足的话
他这个时候就会去抓紧那个被
对
就是这个地方的交互你也得一起考虑改
知道吧
要不现在这个地方
就现在施工这个界面除了施工没人会玩
知道吧
明白
对
就是我觉得你要优化一下
问一下我的想法
我看一下怎么表达出来
对对对
就是现在这个地方因为你还要考虑
那天我跟你说的
可能这里面还有一些IO状态传感器的状态
他这些都不会在程序中体现的
我明白了
我明白对
行那我们继续
这里应该也演示完了
这几个关键的问题
对这里就结束了
行
我我那我来对来
你你那个对对对
我继续共享
刚刚说到的就是2．2的这个问题
实际上它跟2．3的这个是一体的
就是关于这个播放的这个办公
关于它的假取的
这个其实都是这个脚本的逻辑的问题
要合并为一个对吧
并且要解决就是演示跟那个的一个要做区分
就是反正你全盘考虑
把这些问题我觉得肯定是要好的
这里就先不展开去讲了
包括这个IL状态
这个我们也聊到了工具栏
对工具栏感觉那差不多就是第一阶段的话
就是刚刚说的那个工具栏跟模型库的这个就先作为第一阶段的
其他东西都是第二阶段的东西了
帮我把那个软件运行起来
我看一下
我能看到代码对吧
你看不到代码
你给我那个环境我也看不到代码了吗
你要看什么代码
它是一个直接编译好的状态是吧
对
行
我觉得我还是最好还是能够让我直接有代码的
但是我们的不是外部那种
不是外部的
不是你那界面是什么什么技术上的u unity
unit里面的UTI
那我不一定
能搞得定
但是你可以尽量的看一下
看看行能不能调
如果不能调的话
我还得刚刚你原来那套框架搭成跟现在差不多的这个样子
才能够去做方案
我觉得可能不一定OK
因为unity是有license的
不是
就是你们的电脑上就说你另外弄一个机器给我的话
也也是也是不能的是吧
他也算安全上
对你那个远程是可以给你看那个
就是可以操作这个界面
操作这个软件
那我知道了
那那没关系
那我再想办法好了
行那就划分
刚刚阶段我也说了
就是这几天的话
我就先抽时间把工具栏模型库这两个网页给调了
我上次是不是调了一个版本
发过给你们那个那个窗口排版的吗
是吧
是张建那边吗
还是施工这边有过你那个
我
不记得
张建你那边之前
之之前是发在群里面吗
好像发了一个网页的
对对对
我之前在群里面有发过一个
我我我那我就基于那个来去做吧
也行
我接
然后
张建
你那边有没有多的电脑
多的也就说多的我这边好像也没有
除了自己家里面的那没了
我的意思是给设计师这边能够远程看的
不行
我可以白天把家里面电脑开着
远程给他看一下
那你在家里面
在晚上跑跑起来
这个软件可以跑
可以跑
其实你看什么时段方便
如果你要是晚上的话
我这边就可以开给你
如果是白天的话
我的就不一定
可以行
行那其他没什么了
就这几个问题
对
然后可能你要看一下什么些时间点能够给到这个
那个不一定
我刚刚说的那个抓取脚本的那个东西
我还得
你得研究一下是吧
对对对
我得研究一下
可以对吧
争取下周
然后我觉得是这样
关于IOY那些的
你到时候可以跟张建再交流一下
因为他们之前在新控那边有做过一把类似的
你可以张建到时候你可以给他看
给设计师看一下张星空那边之前是怎么制作的
那有没有存货资料可以先填
之前我们比如说像传感器这种
其实我们是有一个传感器的模型的
然后能明确的看到那个传感器是你比如说有物料进来检测到之后
它会变红或者变变绿色那种
有界面的什么文档
直接看一下界面
界面现在好像不一定能
不一定好
我待会儿找一下看看
对你就发群里
我待会找一下
看一下链接还有没有
好好的
就是那个软件
现在外人好像用不了
反正有资料的话
先发我就发
我理解一下
这你那个是我
这边没有什么其他问题了
Hello其他人有没有什么补充的
补充的应该就没有了
我觉得主要就是这几个地方
看看张建你那边还有什么补充吗
应该没有
我觉得现在这个阶段可能这两个设计重要性高一点
然后刚才说的那几个就是统一的设计
可能你要再先看一下怎么优化
因为那个可能跟IO跟那个动作的有一点点关系
但是如果你可以分阶段输出的话
对于我们项目执行来说可能会好一点
因为现在有一些也就因为现在职工已经有很多项目在走
如果那个地方不优化的话
对于他们终端去
比如说销售那边他拿这个东西去演示的时候
其实会出现歧义
就他他他其实本来应该是点那个程序运行
但他点那个上面他其实不动的
就现在会出现这种情况
那那对于这种情况
我觉得可以先有一个过渡方案的优化
对就是这个地方其实现在对对
现在这个地方可能会影响大一点
因为现在销售因为毕竟对于销售人员来说
我们不可能一个一个去培训这个东西
就是通过界面语言去表达它要运行的时候
我们告诉他这个运行的是什么东西
出问题了
对
因为对于他们来说
仿真的运行对于前端销售来说
这块他们的需求会多一些
而且现在我们真正你可以理解为仿真的项目可能有是可能只有50%不到是真正落地的
对
可以
他其实这个时候也是现在那个运行也是在那个动作编辑器那里面去运行
对吧
是的
但是他只是他发给的是施工这边的那个3D前端
明白
明白明白
那直接就是说发只有勾选出来是发给前端跟实体是吧
发给访仿真的模拟
这个前端跟实体有勾选
这里任意至少一个才能运行
这是不是就解决了
我可以这样理解吗
那你说
你什么意思
就是我们现在在动作编辑器那里已经有一个运行的那个图标
对吧
它是一个播放图标的东西
然后我们现在的话就把它叫做什么来着
是发送
对吧
就是不要把它定义为发送
它就是一个执行这个图标
执行的这个按钮而已
然后执行的这个按钮激活的前提是给他设两个勾选
一个的话就是在真机当中去执行
那他执行这个动作也就是包括了下载这个程序
那就发送下载这个程序去运行
还有一个勾选
就是勾选我们仿真这个环境里面去运行
这两个只有勾选任意至少一个才能够运行
如果是没有连接登记的话
那个呃呃真机的那个就勾选就没法打勾
是不是现在这样可以先解决刚刚说的
我没办法培训所有的这些前端的一线的销售人员什么之类的
但是这里面有另外一个问题
就是现在他的手就是最上面那个那个栏那里怎么处理的
上面的蓝我觉得不要了
先暂时不要
整个不要
对
因为他有歧义
他相当于是包了两个
但是我又不确定他是哪一个
之后要做那个脚本是统一的
你怎么样都要经过脚本的吗
有个事情要跟你说一下
因为这个控制的话
控制它一它snow和流程图它都可以控制
刚才给你看那个项目
那个
流程图是走那个女的
然后他也可以走流程图的那他两边都可以控制
那会有什么影响呢
也不一定说是三选一的
我不太明白你共享你再讲一下
就是说这个地方的可运行
刚才我点了一个重置
然后这个地方是那个图
这边它也是可以运行的
这流程图他这边
然后这个程序在编写的时候跟那个block也是完全分开的
是吗
对
就是不是就是说相当于他写了两套程序
一套是用block写的
一套是用流程图写的
实际业务当中也是有是必要写两套的吗
还是说不是
这是二选一就可以了
但是有些项​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌目他们因为之前写了一套
然后后面又写了一套
也就是说刚刚我说的那个方案当中
如果是要运行的话
其实还是要指定一套它的这个程序的
对不对
对然后这个程序的话
无论是blockly还是这个流程模块里面配出来的
它其实都是可以控制实体跟这个动画的对吧
对
那其实就是相当于有有两个选择了
第一个的话就是哪一套程序
第二的话就是甄姬还是动画
对
但是可能这边有个小问题就是
流程图这里是可以从任意入口的
这怎么理解
工程共联试一下
内容入口返回的右键
从这里执行
他意思就是说可以一点击这个播放的时候
他是从开始这个节点往下面走
然后就是你要是单步走的话
也可以这种这个地方单步走一步
也可以从再看这边往下面走
那我明白了
也就是说我们不能
我刚刚那个方案可能有一个问题
就是说我当我去点击的时候再配置可能会有
因为它是可以暂停的
它是可以暂停从任何一个地方暂停再继续
的那我明白那我明白了
其实要我现在要想到的第二个就是说我们把那个配置变成一个跟变成一个语境的配置
变成一个全局的配置
怎么理解呢
就是我们现在上面的那一条里面
它现在其实也是有一个配置的
对不对
仿真登机还是孪生两边
这一是这样吗
我我的想法我的想法是因为按照你刚才说的选一种的话
那就是是那就是点击启动的时候
相当于这个地方它是可以发消息的
就点这个按钮
如果你book和流程图
其实相当于是这三个按钮选一个就点他
意思就是你
就可以
做成那种编辑的
就是编辑我现在如果是点这个按钮可以运行
就是说他这里的显示这个案例
比如说如果说是lock你这边的话
那这边就显示这个界面
如果说是流程图这边的话
那么他出来就是流程图这个界面进行点击了
要不
你说的是要有一个二次确认的过程吗
不一定
就是说你看一下
反正逻辑原理你知道了
你就看怎么交互上优化
因为这地方的话
这个地方就不显示这个播放按钮
然后就在这个地方它就点击
就是你就不用说这个具体的
我这这个
他给你这块
你自己考虑
好吧
反正你知道问题点在哪里
知道了那个block里那里有没有刚刚说的流程图
这种从中间开始
这种的有也可以
也有也是
不行的
不也不行
但是他可以从那个里面走
对
但是他可以从外部出发
比如说外部他他那不是有个函数
自定义函数看到没
定义函数那里
他可以通过外部去发一个消息到这个自定义函数
它就从这里开始了
明白了
对
所以理论上来说也是可行的
其实现在这个也有它的逻辑合理性
就是孪生仿真跟真机其实就是当下你要去运行的一个语境的配置
吧
对
但是这样的就是因为大多数的仿真情况
或者说他其实是要去确认这个步骤行不行
所以他其实有时候会说我不想从比如说我改了这个参数
我不需要从头走到尾
我就只想走这一步看看对不对
对
所以我们才设计的这个从当前步骤开始
对吧
我想到了像很多的IDE里面的第八个是有有这种功能的
就是你运行整一个程序还是
我们我们这个功能就是一样的
跟debug的那个功能是一模一样的
是吗
对
我明白了
其实开发安卓应用的时候也是这样子
对不对
你运行的时候
你也要考虑我运行的是在真机
还是在本那个本那个电脑上面模拟吗
是啊
一样的
而且我们还这里面可能到真机的里边了
你还要看它是不是对应到那个机械臂
对应到那个地方
对吧
我明白了
你可以理解为我们这个就是个IDE
只不过这个图形画的高
自动化ID对
我明白了
但是这个好像没法提前给一个什么方案
现在先想一想
你先想
反正没事
这个属于没有这么特别紧急
但是也很紧急了
因为现在已经蛮多项目
至少这个阶段施工还能应付过来
如果再多些项目的话
他这边可能就够就搞不过来了
因为我们现在就三个人
反正这个是一线人员经常碰到的比较困惑的问题
对不对
对
因为他编完了他就得不停的去演示
然后他他就得不停的去说
告诉客户这个地方我是怎么做的对吧
现在他们碰到的问题就是点了演示之后不知道运行在哪里
对
有时候他就想点那个地方
他就不知道该从哪里入手
然后另外那个block里面有一个编辑的那个地方
他就不知道为什么你一定要锁定还有什么就是这些交互就现在等于上面的那个锁定
锁定是什么
这里就是对于用户来说
现在这一行交互其实是他们不太理解的
第一只读模式
这个发送代码
然后还有这个地方在这里自动启动发送
对于他们来说
这里的交互其实是不止广安的
我也不太明白
那能逐个讲一下吗
逐个快速讲一下
讲一下这个
就是说这个功能的话
这个只读就是怕别人去随意拖动
改动了
它编辑保险控制他不能够通
对
懂懂了
懂了
然后这个保存的就是你修改完之后
对block里面它就会把这个数据进行保存
保存block你还需要把这个发送
就是把它转成为不
其实把它具体的代码放到控制器里面可执行
因为block也是不可执行的
这种开成语句
才可以进行执行
那个发送的作用就是为了生成这个数据
你要改了之后
他才能够运行最新的
然后他是先每次运行的时候是先要如果要在真机上看先发送
然后再点隔壁的那个运行是吧
对
这才是最新的最新的修改
明白
然后刚才那个地方也是一样的
就是这里大概有多个程序在这里
明白
所以这里的操作其实跟刚才那个是小图标是一样的
发送运行停止这个
保存的发送可以做成一个吗
我其实我们是真的有现成参考的
就是一般涉及到真机的
像刚刚说的安卓的开发
叫​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌小程序的开发
包括那些什么来着
对应到的那个IDE
它肯定都会涉及到这种问题
运行的时候要不要运行到真机
我去参考一下他们是怎么弄的
应该是有一种共识的范式的
如果共识的方式我们一线人员都理解不了
咱们再探讨是对不对
我们反正常见的ID就是叫build
对
build对对对
那我们也build然后
就是run
对
是的
或者第8 bug
对吧
对
那我的那个我觉得这个布局上面是刚刚有没有介绍除了我们那个流程跟这个block里的这种可视化
那一列里面还有其他的图标
现在这个关系是指那个功能是什么
那些就是程序的别的东西
你看比如说这是block的方法
哦哦哦就是包装好的东西
就是他在编blo​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌ck里的时候
对吧
对他会需要用到的
了就是模块
函数对吧
然后这个是变量对吧
你可以自定义变量
对
刚刚最顶的那个是什么是什么都没开吗
这个就回到程序了
就是这个程序
知道了这个是一个就是一个工程的是吧
但我感觉像有一点归属关系一样的
所以这里你也可以优化
就是234好像是归属一的那个
对对对
你可以优化
然后关于这个流程图
这里也是流程图
它就并到左边来了
你看到没
对他有一种这样的关系
他应该是有一种这样的关系在的
是是是
所以你可以优化
然后包括最后这里任务管理这个我们也做了一个
就是相当于你可以在里面添加
就是相当于这里面他不是有那个框选吗
你可以在这里面把这里边的一块东西添加成这里的一个子任务
对
然后他就执行那一段程序
先把其中的一段
这一切就比如说机械臂的这一大段
比如说他就是去抓取什么东西
你就可以弄到这里
在这里他就可以因为在周边又另外做了一个更高级的版本
他其实原理是一样的
就是相当于你可以理解为就是把一连串的某个动作组合并成了一个任务
然后这些任务是可以串起来做做条件判断
组合什么流程图也是一样的方式的
明白了
对那个那个就是跟我那天跟你说
后面实验室管理的是有强关联的
一跟那个东西是强关联的
其实因为他做实验
他就是那些步骤的排列组合
那其实到时候是不是也是从这里取呢
是两边同步的是吧
他是从这里取数据的
没错
明白了
所以你先